At this point, I'm going to set you free. The lessons for the rest of this unit
will be showing a number of demos related to more advanced effects. Most of
them have code samples you can look at and see what makes them tick. Rather
than me describing the five things you need to do to enable textures and hook
them up, just look at the code and documentation. 3JS makes many of these
effects surprisingly easy to use right out of the box. Be assured that there
will still be some exercises in the problem set to get you applying some basic
textures to surfaces. However, the effects on the lessons ahead are such that
I'd feel a bit guilty making you connect some bits of code together just to see
the syntax. This is where the roller coaster really starts to go wild and the
best way for you to learn is to rip into the code yourself and see how it
works.